first growing calls for justice in the
horrific death of Tyree Nichols now of
course this gut-wrenching case will be
adjudicated in a court of law rightfully
so but many on the left know just who to
blame and what to blame white supremacy
according to them the five
African-American cops that allegedly
beat Nichols to death are racist
participants in a deeply bigoted system
and that is the narrative now here's the
Time Magazine quote well there can be no
doubt that entrenched institutional
racism lies at the heart of this case
the Boston Globe quote black cops killed
Tyree Nichols systemic racism is the
death of us all Forbes quote five black
Memphis cops upheld institutional and
cultural racism in Tyree Nichols murder
fake news CNN quote the police who
killed Tyree Nichols were black but they
might still have been driven by racism
and CNN's mandir Jones quote if you
think think that the Memphis police
officers had to be white in order to
exhibit anti-blackness you need to take
an AP African-American studies course
that Ron DeSantis just banned and they
always obsessed race obsessed Jamel Hill
tweeted quote the entire system of
policing is based on white supremacist
violence and we see people under the
boot of Oppression carry its water all
the time and here's congresswoman Corey
Bush quote the mere presence of black
officers does not stop policing from
being a tool of white supremacy and she
then accused the government of
slaughtering African Americans at the
altar of white supremacy and on TV the
rhetoric was even worse you decide
I mean the idea that black cops can't be
racist towards other black people on the
street in school at traffic stops must
come as a huge surprise to millions of
black people in this country who've had
to deal with black cops it shouldn't be
a surprise to people
um that uh individual black people can
actually do anti-black things but I
think a race is still on the table we
sometimes forget unfortunately
African-Americans can also be guilty of
hatred and bias and bigotry against
other African-Americans and race still
is involved George you and I spoke about
on the phone because I don't believe
those five cops would have done that to
a young white on a uh on a traffic stop
the fact that it was black officers
shows it doesn't matter the color of the
cop it's the victim how many times do we
have to do we need to see white people
also get beaten before anybody will do
anything
all right everything you just heard
there is false here's something that
will be the ladies of the view
apparently don't know white people do
get beaten by the police in fact far
more uh white people are killed every
year by cops than any other race
according to an online organization that
tracks this data
374 white Americans died during police
altercations in 2022 if you average that
out a little more than one per day I
don't know if the ladies of the view
know any of the names of the people the
374 people do you think the media mob
devotes entire news Cycles to these
deaths that they even count anymore the
number of people shot shot and killed in
Chicago anymore on any given weekend of
course not so why are these incidents
largely ignored according to a study
from Washington State University listen
to this they were reported on by The
Washington Post in 2016 quote officers
are three times less likely to shoot on
unarmed black suspects and unarmed white
suspects and look at this study from the
National Bureau of economic research
covered by the New York Times also in
2016 quote when it comes to the most
lethal form of force police shootings
the study finds no racial bias So based
on both academic studies and actual data
there is no systemic racism in policing
it doesn't exist now of course there are
good cops and I would say that's the
vast overwhelming majority and there is
a small majority of bad cops what we saw
in Memphis was horrible policing from
really bad cops but blaming some kind of
phantom all-encompassing boogeyman is
not going to solve any problems at the
Memphis Police Department or any other
police department around the country now
the left they're not concerned seemingly
at all they're not interested in
actually improving policing they only
seem to care about their own divisive
narrative maybe these Democrats maybe
these media personnel abilities maybe
they're just lying for Pure political
gain or maybe they Harbor racist
animosity and hatred towards people uh
that happen to be white or Asian or
other races uh I don't know maybe they
just don't know the facts or maybe they
just overcome with the emotion maybe
they just pick and choose how come the
99.9999 percent of people that are
killed in any form of violence is rarely
reported on truth always matters uh that
is unless you're Joe Biden hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else